today I'll stick to football all right
Connor made it into the cold of their
hapless bundle - it is cold today I
don't wanna complain cuz great job we
have it's cold today we have a lot to
talk about today I stayed for no guest
you just get me and Connor breaking it
down for you
hey you were today's guess welcome to
second football you should check it out
subscribe on youtube or and have a
podcast where else are we spotify
stitcher do it all but we have a lot to
get caught up on you got in this morning
and I just kind of wanted to start the
show just let's go around the horn
everyone knows if you listen to the show
three times a week hopefully you do that
a lot of times what especially early in
the week what I'm doing is staying out
until 4:00 in the morning talking to
people trying to get information you
know you're holding strong thank you
like I could usually tell when Matt has
had a long night or he's tired and it
looks like he's been responsible and
yesterday before the interview glasses
you're hung over my eyes need a break
every now and then but let's start with
what we're hearing Ian Rapoport of NFL
media reported on what Thursday morning
that's today that the Kansas City Chiefs
are expected to use the franchise tag on
Chris Jones when that window opens later
today actually there's been a lot of
speculation that the Kansas City Chiefs
want to keep Chris Jones there's also
been a lot of speculation Canada that
they want to trade Chris Jones using the
franchise tag really gives them the most
flexibility we saw this last year with
Damian clowny was tagged and then traded
about D Ford was tagged and then traded
so we've seen teams do this in the past
where you want to just keep all your
options on the table basically so the
way that I read this situation is this
doesn't mean anything yet but this is
just giving Brett Veatch in the Kansas
City Chiefs the most flexibility that
you can now say if we don't get a deal
we love a trade offer that we love for
Chris Jones we have options we can keep
him for one year claim under the
franchise tag then if he leaves after
this coming season you're gonna throw
around compensatory pick but now you can
also say we have Chris Jones at a
reasonable salary for one year and if a
team wants to come get him
give us a first-round pick we've seen
that d4 traded last year for a
second-round pick Frank Clark was traded
for multiple picks so what I wanted to
ask you if you're the Kansas City Chiefs
how do you where do you go with this and
then on top of that if your team like
the Miami Dolphins you got three picks
and a ton of
why and you could go get a local guy and
Chris Jill yep that makes the most sense
to me it definitely does I think
priority number one Matt that the Chiefs
have to answer when they go into this is
what is he looking for annually that's
the big question because how much can
the Chiefs pay him now I know a lot of
people look at it and say well obviously
they're gonna give him a home's this
all-world to make an extension when does
the money try up yep for the Kansas City
Chiefs but one caveat in getting this
deal done now if they can is when this
new collective bargaining agreement goes
through I think the salary cap is gonna
see a significant spike where if the
Chiefs can figure this out in the short
term that one to two years of hey how
can we keep everything tight under
budget maybe you do the opposite and
maybe instead of front-loading the
contract you put the big cap hits on the
back end that's one way they can keep an
important player because something you
said to me off-camera Matt is when you
have Chris Jones and Frank Clark
together that's something special it
really matters and if Chiefs can make
this work now I don't think he reports
on the franchise tag so I was surprised
he played last year it's got a new deal
don't think that's gonna happen I was
gonna have it twice so I think it's
either extension which they should try
to find a way to get done or simply a
trade yeah and so I think let's talk
about teams that can actually afford to
do this the Miami Dolphins make the most
sense to me they have picked number five
you know trading five Feltham but you
have 18 and you have 26 and we've talked
a lot about use two twos as well and two
first next year so you have a lot of
room to do this if you are Kansas City
let's just if I'm Kansas City and you
now have tagged Chris Jones you're gonna
talk to his agents and say what do you
want if it's 20 million dollars a year
I'm gonna say okay we're gonna see what
we can get for you if the Miami Dolphins
offer pick 26 for Chris Jones I do that
deal right now me too because that's a
first-round pick it's also 20 million
dollars that you have now to go get a
corner which is gonna be incredibly
important sure to get another pass
rusher whether that's a D lineman or an
exterior guy someone out off the edge
gives you a lot of our study and Brett
Beach is actually drafted pretty well so
if I am now the Chiefs with two
first-round picks and twenty million
dollars extra salary cap space now we're
cooking and I think most importantly
Matt now we're getting real creative
here but this is realistic you can take
those two first-round picks and maybe
you go get a job on Kinlaw maybe you've
right watch the board and see if Derek
Brown starts to slide maybe you get
super
aggressive and you can replace Chris
Jones a great player it's not just you
can replace Chris Jones it's not that
simple but you can find a way to keep
off maybe what it'll be twenty million
dollars all right books is expected cap
it something crazy like that and find a
cheaper option so for the cheeps Chiefs
everything is on the tape oh it is and
at 32
I think d-line is an option Ross
Blacklock that's Marilyn Davidson you
know those are the guys with the pass
rush tools that we expect to be there
late first but if you know like you said
you could package I don't think you're
getting Jeff a CUDA which is too bad
that's man that would be great but with
the corner class I think we've talked a
lot about a Jeff Gladney at 32 Shore
makes a ton of sense jaylen Johnson AJ
Terrell we've thrown a lot of names in
there so it does they've give them a lot
of versatility one thing to put a bow on
the Chiefs and Chris Jones I'll say
about Brett Veatch he's gonna be
aggressive that's one thing we know
about him
he's gonna go out there and make the big
moves if I'm if I'm Beach
I'm calling the Miami Dolphins tomorrow
or just I'm gonna ask Chris Greer
tonight a high velocity in the JW I we
got Chris Jones under the tag for a year
you guys interested in making this move
yeah I think this is the time to feel it
out and I think for the Chiefs like you
said they are in a position here that
most teams would want to be in because
if you're looking for any tag and trade
candidates on the market I think Chris
Jones actually holds some really good
value one of the I think at times this
year other than Aaron Donald you could
say he was besties tackle in football
the last two years have been insane been
very good let's transition to another
team and the AFC the New England
Patriots ESPN reported this morning Jeff
Darlington on Thursday morning reported
that Tom Brady was really prepared to
leave the New England Patriots he he's
entering free agency with a mindset that
he could actually leave after 20 years
with that historic franchise what I have
been told and I wrote this it came out
in the scouting notebook Thursday
morning so before this report was that I
was continued to hear he's gonna be back
and that they are waiting and I think I
said this on on our show here like two
weeks ago they're waiting for the CBA
the same thing the Chiefs are doing with
Holmes you're waiting for the CBA same
thing with DAC in the Cowboys we're
waiting on the CBA if it's gonna get
figured out this week or you know before
the new league year begins in middle of
March that changes things like you just
said with the salary cap it changes a
lot of things so I know that everyone
wants to believe that Brady's actually
leaving New England they're just gonna
go put somewhere else but I will say
everything
been hearing for the last two weeks
everything I've been hearing here this
week in Indianapolis is let's just pump
the brakes on that there's plenty of
time there is a there's what three weeks
before the league gear starts there's
plenty of time for Brady and the
Patriots to figure this out and I think
you have to wonder is this little a
little bit of posturing from the Brady
why would it come out now I think that's
what you always have to ask yourself
it's a very very interesting timing and
I think something else we've talked
about on this show is when you look at
the landing spots that make a lot of
sense
there aren't many I mean really going
back to New England is the logical one
we've heard the buzz we've tried to
create it the buzz about the Raiders
before but we still feel like that's a
long shot you hear you know Bruce Arians
mentioned someone like Tom Brady down in
Tampa but you really have to quit and
then the craziness about the New York
Giants no way that I mean that's that's
absolutely nuts we're not even gonna
address that one but the other two when
you when you keep looking back to it it
all goes back to New England and
anything besides that would be a
surprise so I'm with you Matt and
standing by your original report
anything but him going back to New
England would be a shock and I am
leaving I was doing radio at one of the
the many car washes that you know you
get pulled in here doing this and I got
asked about this as well and said you
know what it what is Tom what does he
want money if he wants money okay he's
gonna leave few of us to win if he wants
to continue to build that legacy he is
staying and I for me that is what it
comes down to he has to decide and I I
don't know but he has to decide which
this is is it a money grab you got two
years left or is this
I want another ring because if he wants
to win no one else makes sense and maybe
for the first time in his life Tom Brady
wants to go out and go through the free
agent experience because if he doesn't
do it now he'll never get to do it again
you get to sit down and hear teams pitch
to you you get to meet with other
coaching staffs and at the end of the
day if he doesn't like anything they
have to say where his heart is always
going back to New England that's fine I
just really think this is an experience
thing for Brady and once again anything
but New England would still be a shock
to us on this show right I mean I've had
times in in my own career where you know
my deal with Bleacher Report's coming up
and and there's a little bit of that
like oh like what I whatever goes
somewhere yeah say ten years here I'm
Tom Brady in this thing you know it's
like at some point it's like you know
what you have you know you know the
people you're gonna work with you know
how it works there's value in that we're
like winning you exactly and you like
winning Bill belch
still there pretty good place to be
other news fridge seat does kick off in
a couple weeks but it actually kicks off
this week all the conversations are
happening between agents and players I
think I've told this story before on the
podcast we were here a couple years ago
and I ran into a guy who was the top
offense attack on the market I want to
say his name because I don't know if you
can get in trouble after the fact and he
was here doing some NFLPA stuff he told
me that night where he was signing a
free agency Oh everyone knows I mean it
was a done deal three weeks before free
agency so a lot of stuff is happening
and one of the prizes on the free agent
market that's not a quarterback is
Jadeveon Clowney I was telling some of
our guys before the show that his game
against the Niners week 17 so all the
best games I've seen a defensive end
play he's going to have huge dollar
amounts if he's not tagged by excuse me
he can't be tagged by Seattle so he's
gonna hit the market if he doesn't stay
with the Seahawks counter two names that
I've heard two teams I've heard the
newer Giants and the Indianapolis Colts
the Indianapolis Colts have like 93
million dollars to spend Giants have a
ton Chyna's have a ton as well both
teams need pass rushers both teams the
Giants at for the Colts at 12 extremely
13 both teams kind of out of that range
where they could draft any Elite pass
rusher so looks like Jamie McCanney
could be in their scopes as far as four
agency goes and those two teams make a
ton of sense we've seen the Colts not
only save their cap space but they've
attacked edge and in the draft it seems
like they've just missed at it last year
they signed Justin Houston when he's
healthy he's a productive player you're
still looking for that premier threat on
the edge for them so and I think for the
New York Giants this is a team that yes
they're off to a good start on the
rebuild on offense you saw promise from
Daniel Jones last year we know it's a
qualm barkley is they're starting to
build that line darius sleet and had a
good rookie season that defense needs a
makeover a makeover from scratch and
when you make over an entire unit you're
not just sitting there and going hey
we're gonna draft three new starters on
the defense we're fine two or three
starters in free agency find two or
three starters in the draft and I think
for the Giants not only do they have the
money but this is a franchise that has
been aggressive in free agency in the
past yeah surprisingly so go out and
spend not all the VOSA panned out Nate
sold her last year I think it's a reason
we're saying hey they're gonna draft the
tackle at four and get their pass rusher
in free agency so doesn't mix lessons
and for the Colts like you said they've
they've tried they've
own draft picks at pass rushers they
brought in just in Houston they value
the position badly and I think they know
to win you got two very good linebackers
there now I think they know to win they
gotta be able to get to the quarterback
now let me follow this Jadeveon Clowney
conversation up with a guy that also
could be tagging trade what are we
talking about with the Anakin gawk way
yeah that's that's a valuable value
extremely valuable piece on this market
if Jacksonville wants to move on one
thing I have heard that he does not want
to come back he's ready to move on and
since the signs out on Twitter a lot
that's well also Tom Coughlin I don't
think he can be understated how damaged
Tom Coughlin left this Rams he was done
right a lot of guys you know tell him
Smith quit football and I not all the
player go to Tom Coughlin but I think a
lot of it is being placed on him so when
it comes to in Gok way they expect him
to be on the move I think they're gonna
make a push to try to keep him but that
is another guy who could be a tag in
trade and he would get a first-round
pick you would be getting a first-round
pick there do you have to they have nine
they have 18 so we could see them having
multiples at nine and 20 I think it is
actually we could see them have three
first-round picks if they move this guy
yeah it feels like a Frank Clark
situation kind of building all over
again with with Yannick over there
because I think the talent is there he's
super young I think he's turning 25 this
offseason
it's crazy he's been very very
productive player and not just with the
sacks but the strip sacks he's somebody
that creates turnovers and gets the ball
back in the hands here often so I think
he's somebody we'll keep an eye on as
the edge market continues to play out
and it's gonna be a pretty strong edge
market in free agency
Wow the draft is so so why Olivier
Vernon is expected to get cut Heller is
gonna be a free agent
there's a lot of names in the not-too
draft class necessarily but the free
agent class on the pass rush market I do
want to go back to the Giants you got
two more notes before we take a break on
the Giants they are expected to be in on
Jack Conklin and this should not
surprise anyone I don't think we're
breaking news with that they wanted to
draft him coming out of college they had
eyes for him he was the problem was we
all knew in the Tennessee Titans jumped
them to draft him at eight overall so
then they drafted who did they did they
take that you're Eli Apple they got Jeff
Weiss jump for Leonard Floyd and ain't
exactly so not a great spot to be in
that's why Jerry Reese isn't the GM
there anymore but I have heard that the
Giants like Jack Conklin he is expected
to get I mean he's gonna be the top paid
right tackle in football it was also in
done but like
said Connor the Giants have plenty of
money to spend yeah and this offensive
line mark it could actually be historic
this year in terms of obviously the
numbers we see it goes up each year but
assuming that someone like Brandon
sheriff does get franchise tag by
Washington
you see Conklin hit the market at tackle
Joe Thune II hit the market at guard
both of those guys Matt are gonna be
paid enormous deals by a lot of
different suitors yeah yeah the
offensive line market again this is a
decent drafted tackle but they're all
expected to go early so if you're a team
you know like the Giants
if you don't draft someone at 4:00 or
even if you do draft Jedrek wills you
can really bolster that line by going
after a Jack Conklin now the last note I
have for you guys the Green Bay Packers
are basically meeting if you're a tight
end here they're meeting with you they
are doing so much work on tight ends
also on the inside linebacker position
but the tight ends for Green Bay they
are all over it and one thing I've heard
guys is that 33 years old Jimmy Graham
is expected to be done there and even if
he stays in a one more year they are
looking at the tight end position I know
they have Jay Stern burner who they like
is kind of a flex item but I think we're
gonna see the Packers do a whole lot of
work on this tight in class now do we
think they look at the inline options
the move tight ends or they're just
looking to bolster the entire room Matt
yeah I think they're just trying to
bolster the entire room that you know
you could talk Kolka met is more of an
inline guy but don't work on your guy
hunter Brian there's another who look
great on the bench press right behind us
yesterday so there are a lot of names
and guys were different types of fit so
I think right now they're just trying to
get better overall tight end welcome
back to the 2020 NFL Scouting Combine we
are live on radio row benchpress will be
going on behind us in about 50 minutes
stop recording Connors gonna get how
many reps 225 can you do I don't know
anymore I mean probably like six I can't
do a very very obviously people watching
this on YouTube can tell which of us
works out more than the other bench I
could never do it even back when I like
lift it everyday or when I played high
school sports like a super bench so it's
not about how really how strong you are
it's about preparing for it like you
could be really strong in a shitty
bencher
which is why they do it here is because
they want to say hey who's been training
for the last two months in this yeah cuz
you have KJ hammer yesterday who's I
mean it's not that between us you'd be
like he's an NFL player right and I
think he did what 13 14 reps right
that's crazy so that's the important
thing with the bench for us I'm excited
it's over here just don't want to see a
guy do like four
you know it's like horse says you're not
trying know you really like do not give
a [ __ ] if you're gonna be able to row
athlete and you did for so that'll be
going on if it was squats oh yeah I'd be
all day that's all I could ever do yeah
not for me
no thanks let's pass right let's talk
about some news though van Jefferson why
don't you around Florida a guy we loved
at the Senior Bowl totally blew up he's
out six to eight weeks they found a
Jones fracture in his foot during the
medical evaluations here at the combine
so he will not be able to perform here
and he's out six to eight weeks this is
a bad time of year to find an injury
it's not only that it's the problem that
this is a really deep wide receiver
class and I think people wanted to see
Van run because yeah one of the
questions with him is speed we know he's
great route runner we know he's tough he
has good hands like a lot of people
wanted to see him run below that four
six threshold and be a you know maybe a
four or five four kind of guy in that
range I know he's he's a build up speed
kind of guy if you go back into his high
school track data that's available but I
think when you look at it Matt yeah it
sucks there's no way around it hopefully
for van that can heal up the right way
not rush and hopefully you know I guess
right before the draft he can hold a pro
day once again I would not rush that six
to eight weeks eight weeks you're a
traffic so it's tough I think it is hard
for him and a guy who so the knock on
van Jefferson is other than speed is
that he didn't produce in college and so
I think that's like you said a deep wide
receiver question I've been saying for
months on this show is this year like
your 15th receiver could be a
second-round pick or he could be a fifth
round pick it's something we're going
through time and time again when you
look at how this class sacks when you
get to the Tier three guys in this class
like you get outside of the you know
Judy CD rugs even see Higgins and
gesture and Jefferson and you get into
rigor and you get into hammer and you
getting the guys like that it's like
well those guys would be no-brainer
probably first rounders but this year
you're looking at second round and then
it has a trickle effect all the way down
the board that's what's happened to van
so it just pushes everybody like Brian
Edwards who's now working out here as
well a guy who I like Brian Edwards I
think he's really good I also think he's
probably gone in the fourth round
yeah he's keeps getting pushed down the
board because of the injuries and I
think with the receiver group even when
it came to measurements we didn't really
see any one where it was like okay
that's different than what we expected
you know a lot of
Senior Bowl data helped but guys like
you know KJ hammer just gonna be a very
good athlete Jalen Rieger who coming in
at 200 pounds like that's great that's
exceptional for him and he's gonna
rocked up very very well yes in a run
exceptionally well that's gonna happen
behind us today Thursday afternoon I
don't forget the workouts are in prime
time now but speaking of measurement
something you and I didn't get a chance
to talk about I spent a little time
honored a couple shows go is the
offensive tackle measurements the top
five guys on my board all came in with
over 34 inch arms that all were you know
height that you wanted them to be at we
didn't see anyone come in at like a low
6 for obviously makai back then one the
way in but I think it's good news for
our guys Jedrek wills it's great news
for Tristan Dwarfs Andrew Thomas and
Josh Jones to all be big on that way and
without a doubt and another thing with
them is their everyone each year we see
the trend is really bucked about the
sloppy offensive linemen these guys just
look like big athletes now they look
like they're in really good shape
they're carrying the weight really well
even vecten comes in you know at a true
365 and he carries that weight really
well Matt so I think through those guys
they did come in and win the
measurements because of the arm length
which really matter matters for someone
like Chris and works is he a tackle me
and you lean on the side that he is
Jedrek wills I don't think there's ever
been a question that he's a tackle but
there had been some rumblings around
that some teams might you know have
questions if he is but it's pretty
simple Andrew Thomas came in you know
very way bigger than anyone expected
those arms and 36 inch arms I honestly
thought it was a typo well I got
somebody fat fingered their keyboard
yeah you know but it's legit and that's
great for him to be indigent like the
height we kind of knew how tall he was
but the arm length is really what
surprised me most for and you know we
know what Josh Jones is these top five
offensive tackles have done themselves
nothing but favors since the season
ended they really have and when we get
questions so you know why isn't Andrew
Thomas the first tackle taken anymore
you know why is Becton not your guys
first tackle taken I don't think any of
these guys have you know fallen really
in the draft board if any some of them
have begun to really rise some of them
have just you go back to the film they
had really really good seasons and now
they come to the combine and start to
build off of that when you not only when
you hear them speak but the measurements
how strong they are how they move the
bottom line is in the biggest point from
all this it's a very good offensive
tackle class and I think there's five
first round starters in this class that
should go into top 20 and Austin Jackson
I still like I know he got beat up in
the Iowa game and the in the bowl game
I still like Austin Jackson like I
wouldn't be shocked if he was picked in
the 30s that's here the non like the
outside the big five yeah we'll call
them the power five of the offensive
linemen here you have really good
players I mean when you look at Isaiah
Wilson from Georgia somebody that coming
out of Brooklyn a five-star prospect
he's huge any weight a really good right
tackle and he comes to the podium and he
says listen Caleb on Chaisson was the
toughest guy I faced and he got him good
with that spin move but you like hearing
guys speak to that so I think once again
you have a lot of good guys on day two
that can be developed as starters and
you have these locks on day one that
teams are really excited about and we
were waiting for someone to fall out of
the pack and no one had know it's like
the pack is getting bigger
yes like instead it's like now I'm
stronger yeah I think they know Jeremiah
said he was a one-man afraid well it
wasn't one man I think he even said that
now you know Austin Jackson's gonna top
15 buzz which is yeah it's kind of crazy
but we saw it last year with a lot of
those guys going earlier than we
expected rising up the board a little
bit
the drills start tonight in prime time
you're probably listening to this on
Friday morning but if you're listening
to when it comes down to Thursday you're
a grinder you're right Thursday night
the drills start tonight and I think
there's a lot of confusion about when
things are going to happen the order
they're gonna go in I've had agents
texting me as we're sitting here
recording this saying do you have any
idea tell me guys that's not good like I
don't I don't know I don't know if the
NFL knows so there is a little bit of
confusion and I'm not trying to
overstate that you know because I had
the report earlier in the week about
agents being worried about their guys
it's just that there's a lot of
confusion tonight so we don't know
exactly when Henry rug's is gonna line
it up I would assume it's during that
prime time window but when we're
watching these drills tonight what do
you look for I know we've I've been
doing this a long time you've been doing
this several years now I don't really
care about the 40 so much is like I care
about the outliers on the 40
if you're running a 4-2 that's insane if
you're running a four six that we got to
talk I was gonna say well what I expect
to happen
I don't really react to like if Henry
rug's runs a four to nine great he's
exactly who we thought he was if Jalen
Rhaegar runs a four three five great
it's exactly who I thought he was right
he
here's where it gets interesting tea
runs a 4/4 I want to see tea go for five
I want to see CD Lam go for five I want
to see Donovan people's Jones jump
through the roof like those are things
that you want to see like you said Matt
you're really checking for the outliers
like it gets scary if some of the top
names run in the four sixes yeah OCD
runs on four six there's a lot I'm just
gonna change a lot of people are gonna
start making excuses but I mean we have
not been shy about this on this show
if excuse me if you have a question my
CD laments that has have a lot of juice
he's physical he's smart he never played
against press coverage and he doesn't
have a lot of juice and so if you don't
have that speed well guess what that's
where those things come into question
and these are when you're looking at a
deep wide receiver class you're looking
at these teams they're you know there's
been reports that the Raiders might be
interested in the first round wide
receiver you know Arizona might be
interested in the first round and wide
receiver you really need to do something
super special nowadays to cement
yourself in that top 15 picks as a wide
receiver and you know even the Jets have
been attached to Henry rugs and all the
people are sitting there and like why
are they gonna let Robbie Anderson walk
just the dress that's one guy now rugs
is even faster than right which is crazy
yeah but but the point is you really
need to do something special so I think
for the receivers here you want to live
up to the hype that's what we're
watching for I'm not necessarily you
know if they do exceed it great but once
again we're watching here I just want to
see them past the thresholds I think a
couple guys that need to stand out
Brandon ioq needs to stand out for me
Arizona State didn't get steamed in the
Senior Bowl he was hurt he needs to run
well here we know how great he is with
the ball in his hands and then I'm gonna
be a homer for a second and Devin
Duvernay has not been talked about
enough as one of the fastest players
here the guy dropped like one pass in
college he led college football and
catches this year I understand he's
limited a little bit he's gonna be a
slot receiver he is hundred meter time
in high school was the best of any
player here
he showed I should fly absolutely like
it should be expected but I think people
are gonna be surprised and I think you
bring up a great point about the slot
receiver argument I was just doing the
the PFF show over there with Mike and
Austin and we're talking about slot
production is still production it's
still offense so if you have a really
really good slot receiver you shouldn't
knock them for only being able to play
the slot if you're getting a lot of
production out of them so you've been
high on Duvernay since we've you know
since the season literally a member we
got back from Texas trip in September
and you were like
I like this guy I don't want know why no
one is evaluating me as a prospect and
it's only it's only gonna get better
from here I believe when people are
listening to this show tomorrow right
and we'll see if his cousin Kyler Murray
tries to get him in Arizona that would
be like how that that's this Kansas City
speed at receiver if the house I'll tell
you not to get completely off track but
I want to talk about Arizona for a bit
I'm very curious to see if cliff is a
guy as we saw last year that's like you
know what I'm gonna find all my wide
receiver gyms outside of the top 50
outside of rounds went to because he's
somebody that has recruited skilled
talent he's someone that believes he
could develop skill talent and he has a
system where skill talent let's be real
Matt is built to thrive so easy Arizona
eight I'm curious if the wide receiver
talk is a smokescreen or if it's for
real I've always thought it was just
because of that like you could have like
last year they take Andy Isabella he's a
good player but he's a very specific
player and it felt like Cutler all their
picks were very specific you know to
we're trying to build out our basketball
team or wide receiver I don't I feel
like they go off in supplying even after
signing DJ Humphries I think they go
Tristan wharfs and boom you're set
that'd be great for them I think that's
how they should build the team
especially when you have Kyler who had a
really really good rookie season they
get production out of anyone they put in
the backfield they trade for Kenyan
Drake and the production just goes
through the roof I hope they keep him so
yeah me too cuz I think it's just it's
where it makes sense for both sides so
for Arizona they're one of those teams
that you really start to wash inside the
top ten relating to this wide receiver
class absolutely people want to read and
I just listen I had a big board come out
earlier this week had a scouting
notebook drop on Thursday morning that
actually gives all 32 teams should get
bus on that three rail mock draft to
come out Monday morning so there's a ton
of content people can have and I we
buried the lead on this all the time I
actually got to meet our guy Joey
Molinaro a couple days ago had a blast
just talking for like ten minutes
the show Saturday our meet up at two tea
brewing company two o'clock Saturday
it's gonna be amazing I can't wait so
now I'm ready that he already met you
because he's building his oh yeah his
impressions I hope not so we could do
the show could be me mellow Joey as Matt
and Matt as Matt so we have to Matt's so
the humble bragging is over the top on
the on the show every times will he say
my homes already in it I can't arias man
it's great and he's a draft fan so he
also just wants to talk football it's
gonna be good so that's a sure you'll
definitely want to be out we always say
it but senior
combine some of our best live shows the
year because you get all different kinds
of fans you get a great turnout and we
love going to 2d right and the music is
starting that means it's almost time for
the bench press we'll take a break we
come back draft on draft for like the
first time in a week let's do it alright
we are back in there playing some
bangers behind us man getting ready for
the bench press they were just rocking
out some Miley I know when I'm in the
gym that's not for me but hey to each
their own
honestly it more of an ariana guy when
it comes to the gym but different
strokes for different folks right hard
rock or rap or like Pantera
actually sometimes I'll throw in some
outlaw country in there Tyler child errs
which I know you're a big fan of Sirte
simpson right yeah I mean I grew up you
know in the like 90s rock it was like
our warm-up for everything so I can
still go to that I still go back to
Pearl Jam Soundgarden all of that it's
hard to find a lot of new music nowadays
where I'm like man this workouts awesome
you're not a Fort Minor guy shockingly
no I'm not like JJ was great for a minor
in the gym I know I'm always like I
would like to watch the players on the
Instagram stories of what they're
working out too and half the time I
won't even yeah I'm judging the music
hard yeah I don't like Kanye and I know
it's a hot take of mine but that is like
good running music so when we called
Lynn Bowden he was like oh I'm at the
facility yeah like the it was you can
hear him like he had to step out into
the hallway obviously said and we've
been access for they're just it's
blaring at all hours like it is here
right now we did want to answer some
drafts on Drive questions since we're
back together let's start here with
Travis Johnson he asked this Neville
Gallimore sighs make him scheme specific
or do you feel like he can play a knows
Garden two three four or d-tackle in a
4-3 feel like he's bigger more explosive
than Ross black like who came in at 290
pounds mr. price
I'm like Gallimore can do I think that
he's a like I think he could play one
technique I don't think I would ever
want to put him on top of a center on
top of a guard I think he's a gap type
player his quickness is really good so I
think of him it's like could he play in
a one technique yeah he probably could
but I actually see him as a three
technique
six to 304 a little bit short but I
think he can penetrate still I was gonna
say when you go back to the film of what
he did best this year I think goes back
to what you just said Matt where you
don't want him over the nose tackle like
that he's somebody that was
Xplosive this year I thought he had a
really underrated season we always talk
about how that defense never seems to
have a lot of impact players and this
year they had a handful and I like that
you brought up Blacklock because I think
he got down to 290 here to show
explosive videos and I think he's
playing weight will go back above 300
but you know I was reading that there
was a time at TCU where he was waiting
3:30 to be at 40 pounds lighter than the
combine when you watch the film he does
some freaky stuff ya know he's a good
player I think he's a first round player
Brad Pound asked this we kind of touched
on this earlier if t Higgins runs to sub
for five today what will that do to his
draft stock so it won't change his
ranking for me but I think I'll mock
drafts we'll start right now I always
have him like 22 23 maybe 21 22 23 we
would probably talk about a little
earlier if that's the case I think with
T yeah if you're like a team like the
bills or Packers you got to start
thinking about trading right so I don't
think you'd make it a Green Bay anyway
but I think the bills is someone where
that's usually his landings but that
usually is where he comes off the board
and a lot of mocs right the Broncos at
15 and Judy CD and rugs are gone if he's
a 4-4 guy you're probably thinking about
that a little bit T Higgins a Cortland
Sutton on each side I bet you're playing
basketball out there just throwing up
alley-oops
and I think with T he almost doesn't get
enough love on this show we really liked
him a lot over the summer coming into
this wide receiver class where we put
his name with Judy CD yeah you know that
kind of ranking and once again it goes
back to the teens the Andrew Thomas of
this class he didn't do anything wrong
this year just some guys did some crazy
stuff to go above him but he's still a
really really good first round playing
still my fourth receiver like still a
top 20 player I think it's the best
vertical threat that's the thing the way
he plays above the rim yeah it can help
out a quarterback and that's a
difference maker but how he runs is
something he's going to be scrutinized
on because he's someone that a Clemson
one deep and a lot of people still don't
expect him to run really well so you're
gonna go back and say if he does run
well at his size you're like wait
because he was he was winning deep
because he is really fast right exactly
here's a fun question from Garrett
Greenlee if all these guys were
available in this draft as prospects
what order would they go in Jared Goff
Baker Mayfield Kyler Mary Jo burrow so
basically the last four quarterbacks go
number one
that's tricky but not for me what I
think the NFL would do or you can rank
them if you want that's really tricky
cuz I really liked I liked all of them
actually what am I saying I go back and
do it like I am
I like to cough yeah I love to cut me
and you loved Kyler yep
and I think Kyler's the only one of the
three that's lived up to ironically he's
had the shortest time in the NFL to get
it short it's no pun intended on
aggressive yeah I'm not going don't go
there
not going there that is really really
difficult so really did the way I would
have had it graded would be burrow golf
Murray Baker I think I would have had it
created golf Kyler bake Oh Baker and
burrow are gonna be really close yeah
really close
I had Kyler I think fourth or fifth
overall Goff I think I had like second
or third overall I mean I thought and he
could still turn it on
Gotha is crazy to me because we've seen
MVP type moments no we've seen play
where he should not be starting right
like Bowen and I were talking about on
the show yesterday if he has to move off
his spot he can't come back which is not
a good thing nowadays no that's what
everyone Baker he can really really
bounce back this year by the way like
the saying that he booked up last year
he got fat yeah he didn't bulk up look
at me
right it just gained weight like bulking
up to me he's like muscle you've worked
out you've at him like everyone that's
here in Indy all these players are
coming in they add 20 pounds and they
don't look like heavy right look muscley
yeah he looks chubby so that's and I'm
not making this to hate on Baker show
because I'm just saying he can bounce
back really well next year right I think
it is an important point for him to slim
down and get some of that quickness back
that he had I all I will say is all four
of those guys are are really good
quarterback prospects now if you were
ranking it by the league the way they
had it I mean people in the NFL loved
Jared Goff yes Baker Mayfield very torn
yeah extremely I think of the four Baker
was the most divisive of those Tyler
Murray pretty torn on people are not
torn on Joubert jobber oh no so Goff and
burrow would actually lead that group
before yeah and it was crazy they're
kind of similar
I mean burrows much better on the move
but yeah spotty type similar the arm the
touch strings the touch throws is is
really you know where they both win in a
lot of ways and the conversation around
burrow just I thought it would be like
the most boring thing this year cuz like
I was going number one he's really good
player we're done but it just it gets
juicy man now I'm saying he's not a good
prospect I need to go back on and talk
to Colin about that I know people get
upset but I think Colin's really fun
right it's entertainment I just had this
conversation with some people over there
I'm like there's a difference we
entertainment in sports and when they
mix together you need to understand what
it is right
I like Colin I mean I understand this
just like I go on there and it's good
for me but I like him I listen to his
show I think it's funny I obviously I
disagree with him at times but I also
understand why he's saying it I mean I
think he puts thought into his rants I
agree this isn't he's not going full
Steven a yeah I think I think Joe
barrows a really good quarterback
prospect so I don't agree how you don't
agree with it either but I like I know
what he's saying like he doesn't have a
big arm yeah and it's just he needs
someone to come on and because here's
the question he's gonna ask us what is
what does he do great and so he's poised
he keeps his eyes downfield he's
accurate I'll say this when that
question is asked I think it's even
easier than some people make it out to
be his feel in the pocket is legendary
it really is legendary the best I've
evaluated I would I'm trying to think
who we had that's better like feel mm-hm
I think Cuyler has a good feel but
Cuyler just loves to leave right so he's
a little early Joe is like oh no I
couldn't find my way to get back in the
pocket I think Melo said it in like
September and we kind of made fun of it
it's Tom Brady in the pocket that's who
he reminds me of yeah yeah yeah Tom
doesn't move like that but is he as
smartest I hate to say it but the goat I
don't know about that right I know
that's what stuff but like Brady's just
the Brainiac mm-hmm but Joe's got a
little fire in him I think we've seen a
different kind of swag with him so this
is something let's just be transparent
in our group chat we've talked a lot
about our perception of Joe borough
did it change for you this week with how
he handled the the podium um I thought
it was well handled I don't know why it
took like I feel like it took a lot to
get here and he did say like the media
created it he didn't want to be
presumptive I thought he handled that
well of like yes why should I have to
come out and say I would play for a team
that hasn't
to me I'll say this about it like I
haven't spoken directly to jail borough
everyone you talked to whether it's at
the LSU program or and we'll talk to
plenty of his teammates and hopefully
geo himself or people in the NFL love
him where I take the word for it where
it's like I think he's gonna be just
fine character wise the NFL he is very
confident very but if he wasn't we would
trash that it's impossible you know it
is impossible it really is you know and
I'm not saying this because he's my
quarterback because he's been very very
up and down but I feel like Donald is
the best being in the middle no would
that Adele does he's not like he always
says the right thing to the point where
you're like can you just say something
out of line yeah and I like the borough
will be a little Collins the same way
and no coincidence they're best friends
Allen and Arnold but yet borough is he's
not Baker but he's more towards the
Baker no matter what Melo will say
something much more towards that line
though closer to it where it's like oh
like you definitely think you're the
[ __ ] that's okay it's almost like
Roethlisberger a little bit yeah but Ben
has yeah just enough [ __ ] you
I don't yeah I just don't want to put
him in that category right yeah you
don't I'm not comparing anyone but yeah
just in terms of that he's got a little
fire to him for sure I also I mean going
back to that conversation of character I
think and you've seen it here not just
to uh to has been phenomenal like people
just love being around to a Justin
Herbert has been very impressive it's
done a good job and he deserves to the
critics and fix that he deserves a lot
of credit because he went to the Senior
Bowl you know obviously his presser here
but just everywhere he's gone since this
draft process has begun for him I think
Justin Herbert you know honestly
deserves a lot of praise for I know it's
a question I brought up on the show my
cat you know how fiery is he yeah and
he's just proven it the entire tire way
it's funny because like a year ago and
headed into this season that's really
all we talked about what's it like oh we
know he's talented yeah and now it's
like I mean he did a hell of a job of
working at that of being a better leader
more vocal leader cuz not everyone's
born that way it's not something you're
naturally comfortable with all the time
right but you have to you have that if
you want to be a cool if you want to be
one of the 32 starting quarterbacks the
NFL you have to be kind of work on it
alright that is our show we will be back
Friday we'll be doing a show so you guys
will get that Friday afternoon
Saturday morning
and then Saturday obviously our event
with Melo would join Molinaro two
o'clock from two deep run company here
in Indianapolis it's free for 21 and or
over you can come out on their time on
and under when he wanted oh no not that
kind of party man yeah that's our show
we'll talk to guests tomorrow